Subtitles by the Amara.org community
Can you guys hear me through this?
Uh-oh, I think all my audio is messed up.
Hold on.
What's going on?
Output is on.
You can, okay.
Hold on, give me a second.
I don't know why, it might be double once I fix this.
Oh, hold on, let me check this.
Streaming...
Pretty, thank you for the 50 gifted, thank you!
What the heck?
It was just working!
Oh, wait, you can hear this, wait.
I'm so confused.
We got the music.
Hold on, let's see if we can hear the game.
I think you can.
Yippee!
Hold on.
It's a little loud, right?
Seven?
Sixty?
Actually, I don't know if that changed anything.
Okay.
I'm so...
The audio is low for me all around.
Yeah, but because...
Because it was lowered, because I had to turn on a different setting.
I'm so confused.
I guess I'll just use this then.
Wait, hold on, let me check if it works.
Hmm...
Weird!
Much better?
Sorry if that was a jump scare.
Um...
Okay.
Now I feel really weird.
Now I feel all discombobulated.
Perfect volume?
We're good?
Okay.
I sound cleaner?
I don't know.
If I should sound cleaner...
It's all the same.
Whatever.
Bread is pain.
So true, Minecraft.
Anyway...
Welcome back!
Master!
Lady!
Welcome!
Welcome...
To...
Minecraft!
I, um...
I truly have no plans.
Um...
I have no plans.
I'm just kind of...
Thanks for the thank you!
Thank you!
I just felt like playing.
So, I'm Mirai.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
What is this new game?
I know!
My gosh!
Yeah, we're gonna punch trees.
As you can see, I have no servers.
So, um...
So...
It's just gonna be you and me, baby.
It's gonna be just us.
It's gonna be single player mode.
All on our own.
We're gonna be...
We're gonna be fighting for our lives.
You and me together.
Solo venture.
Yeah.
A date?
Not a date.
Don't say it like that.
That's weird.
A date with me and...
However many people are in here.
Don't say it.
It makes me anxious.
Someone is third wheeling though.
One of you guys...
One of you guys is third wheeling.
So...
I have my new cat in here with me.
At some point, she might want to be let out.
I don't know.
She's kind of doing her own thing.
I'm...
I'm watching over her because she did not have a very good morning.
And I was so worried about her.
I thought I would be having to take her to the vet.
But I think she's okay now.
That's the new cat called Adamska.
Me like being third wheel pain.
Bread is pain.
She doesn't have a name yet.
She dies.
Hi kitty.
She's... I don't know.
She's behind...
I think she's laying in the bed over there.
So...
Finally got mine grabbed.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for the super dots.
Thank you.
Is it MGS related?
What?
Why?
Why would it be...
Why would it be ...
MGS related?
Why...?
Why would it be...
Why would it be MGS related?
Motherfuckin'...
Minecraft lights...
Go.
Sakha, thank you for the pink.
First time, huh.
Playing Minecraft?
Oh, okay.
You guys, it's a bit of a fib, okay?
I'm sorry.
This isn't my first time playing Minecraft on this channel because a couple years ago, Lyrica, Nova, and I, we all did a haunted Minecraft mod map on my channel.
So it's a bit of a lie.
I'm sorry.
Hold on.
I'm bowing.
I'm so sorry.
Lying is bad.
It's clickbait.
It was clickbait.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, Tuber, why you lie?
But this is the real time playing just regular Minecraft.
Yeah, I clickbaited because I'm sorry.
I'm a real YouTuber.
Let's see.
I'm excited to see what our world is going to be.
What should we call it?
That's the first thing we got to do.
What do we call the world?
Also, should I do like hardcore?
Wait, this is hard.
No.
Oh, wait, it would be hardcore.
Hardcore.
Outer Heaven.
Bustin' World.
Made World.
Phantom Zone.
Outer Heaven.
Bustin' Zone.
Oh, Bustin' Z!
See you on the next episode of Made World Outer Heaven Bustin' Z!
Perfect.
Good job, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
I wonder what kind of... where we're going to start.
I hope it's somewhere good.
Cows!
You guys are in Minecraft.
Hopefully, there's no lag.
How's the audio, by the way?
Just let me know.
I can change anything you want.
We're in a jungle.
Go punch a tree.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Wait, where's my...
Oh, okay.
I need four of these.
Okay.
Crafting...
Oh.
Crafting table!
I want it to be neater, though.
Complete.
The two by two.
Crafting table.
Okay.
Let's go explore the land a little bit.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I can... Oh, yes.
Check me out.
Yippee!
I'm beautiful.
Oh.
I'm next to this cow.
Oh, oh, hold on.
I don't want to fall into a hole and, like, die immediately, but...
Oh my god.
Wait.
I... Oh, this is the water.
I was gonna say I could have fallen into a hole and died immediately.
Who's that creeper?
Oh, man.
Um...
So, uh...
Yesterday, I was supposed to stream...
Oh!
I just realized my eyes.
So...
I'm always so excited when I'm running around.
Sorry.
But I have to open my eyes to be able to play the game, you know?
She's a professional.
She learns so fast.
So pro.
I can't help that I'm just a gamer.
I adapt, you know?
Being a gamer is all about adapting quickly.
I don't want to go down there just yet.
We have nothing.
Am I playing?
Oh, I'm in pla...
I'm playing in hardcore mode.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot.
Okay.
Wait.
We actually need to get some stuff then, don't we?
We actually need to get some stuff.
Like this little flower.
Today, I do want to build a little maid cafe.
I want to do that.
So...
This game seems interesting.
Hope it gets popular.
It's just like a little kind of indie, right?
I think.
It's a little indie.
Probably like a school project or something.
Hardcore maids.
Speaking of maids.
Yesterday, I finished Akiba Maid Wars.
I finished the show last night.
And...
Wow.
That was...
Oh.
I forgot to finish my sentence from before.
But...
How was it?
Let me finish what I was saying before and then we'll talk about it.
It was...
I forgot...
Or not.
I forgot.
I did not stream yesterday.
So, I'm streaming today on a Monday.
If you're watching the VOD...
Hello.
Thank you.
It might not be Monday for you.
But...
So, I wanted to make a video.
I wanted to make up for it with at least streaming today.
A little bit.
And...
I just got...
No.
I just got Minecraft yesterday.
So, hopefully...
You guys can backseat a little bit for me if it's okay.
Tuesday here.
It's Tuesday.
I'm dying.
Oh, God.
Maybe you guys should tell me that I should not drown.
Oh, my gosh.
It's April 29th.
Colonel.
We managed to avoid drowning.
Real.
Oxygen is important.
Okay.
Let's make ourselves a...
The real crafting table.
I should eat.
Are there any birds around here?
But...
Yeah.
So, I wanted to make up for it.
I don't...
Do not have a schedule this week that I'm writing out because my week is kind of like a little bit weird.
So...
I will...
Is that a Skeleman?
In the day?
You're not welcome here.
So...
I apologize.
But I will be putting up waiting rooms for streams that I have.
That I have confirmed for this week.
Such as I have a Metal Gear stream up for tomorrow, April 30th.
It's totally radical and cool.
Rude.
He's just minding his business.
I'm not.
This is my business.
This is my...
I've colonized this place.
It's mine.
I'm the ruler here now.
But yeah.
So radical and cool.
It's so awesome.
Another thing...
Uh oh.
We're hungry, you guys.
This is...
Friday I have a collab.
If you watch the Helldiver stream...
Oh!
A bird I can eat!
Wait.
No.
This is not a bird I can eat.
Sorry.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's eat some cows.
Where?
Skelly and spider?
Bo?
Bozo?
Wait.
Where?
Why are they so close?
Why are they so loud?
Okay.
Please die.
Please.
Okay, gosh.
Awesome.
It's just the Aurora Borealis.
What should the next world's name be?
Don't say that!
Look, I'm punching pigs now, okay?
I'm punching pigs!
Doesn't this music really relax you?
During all of this.
Are they right there?
Oh, shoot!
Run, run, run, run, run, run!
Okay, I saw...
Ouch!
Okay.
We're fine.
He's not gonna come out.
He's an idiot.
Can't even stand the sunlight.
Okay.
Let's punch some more trees.
But yeah.
So...
I'll be doing a collab with Matara Henya...
Hold on, let me actually...
We confirmed this, right?
Yes!
Matara, Henya, and Haruka on Friday for Left 4 Dead 2!
So...
Don't vomit this time.
No guarantees this time.
So I'm excited for that.
That will be Friday.
8 p.m.
EST.
Oh, you guys are starting to get dark.
But yeah, I wanted to just mention that about the...
What is this?
Are these guys okay?
I've never seen the wolves of this color before.
New wolf types?
They added new wolves?
What?
Really?
There are different colored wolves now.
Regional wolves!
No way.
You guys are lying.
What?
There's wolf armor too?
Oh, they're so cute.
They look like dogs.
It's my first time seeing them ever.
Oh gosh.
Another one?
Why are there skeletons?
Get him.
I think we should build a boat.
And leave this place.
Leave this world behind.
We need bones.
We don't need bones.
Oh, I also have the bamboo wood.
How do I make that?
Bamboo wood.
Block of bamboo.
Oh no!
I can only make one.
Okay.
Boat.
I think I want to find...
I want to find...
Cherry blossoms.
It's starting to get really dark.
Goodbye, world!
Let's go.
Nothing can hurt you on the boat at night.
See, this is the most relaxing.
I'll be honest.
This is actually music that I listen to almost every night.
When I'm cleaning or winding down or anything.
You can't get me.
You can't hurt me.
Fool!
This is what I'm listening to at home.
Yeah.
So.
Akiba Maid War.
What is this?
Oh my gosh!
A coral!
Um.
I...
I actually really quite liked Akiba Maid War, but the ending...
was so...
Wow!
The ending was...
Very sudden, yes!
It was very, very sudden.
I'm just gonna steal...
Oh.
Can I...
Do I have time to steal this?
I think so.
Okay.
Let's go.
See ya, suckers!
Now I have light.
The ending was...
It was, yeah.
Um.
There's always time for theft.
True.
Where are we going?
I wonder.
What will we find in this world?
This spectacular Minecraft world.
This looks lit up over here.
What is it?
Oh, I think it's just...
More...
Coral.
Leave that guy alone over there.
I was just listening to talk about the Russian maid on the podcast.
Yeah!
Oh yeah, the podcast came out today.
If you guys didn't listen, please do.
We are silly, goofy gals.
It certainly ended.
I did not watch the show.
It's like...
I don't want to say a bittersweet end.
But it is kind of bittersweet.
I actually didn't hate it.
At first I was like super shocked.
Sorry, I'm trying not to spoil anything in case anyone's like...
Um, Mint?
I was going to watch Akiba Maid War right after this.
I'm trying not to spoil, but...
It was good.
I'm excited to make my summer list.
Yeah!
He's got armor on.
I need that.
Wait!
This is a mesa biome!
That's mesa biome!
I thought it was a village.
Um...
Hmm...
I think we could just run through this.
Steal the armor.
Hmm...
Let's...
Let's carry on through.
Do you like the jazz?
Bozo Ranger?
I don't think there's any saxophone.
This is relaxing.
Just Minecraft sounds and jazz.
I really needed to wind down today.
Because...
To give you guys an idea, so I got my cat recently.
And she's so sweet and so cute.
Do we need a bucket for the list?
Preferably.
When I got my cat...
It's been a...
It's been like a little over a week.
And um...
Uh...
She's kind of bad.
In that she will get on...
I'm training her not to get on the counter.
But she currently likes to get on the counter.
And uh...
You know...
Um...
Get into things a little bit.
But um...
Hey, hey, don't pay attention to me.
Maybe if I go around this side.
I'm trying to get to the other side.
Oh my god, run.
And um...
But she got into the counter last night.
Or she got on the counter and got into some stuff last night.
Um...
I forgot to put away Butaro's food.
And she ate it.
And I don't think she had a good reaction to it.
And um...
She was like...
She threw up the most amount that I've ever seen a cat throw up.
First of all.
Which was very shocking.
I was like, whoa.
I didn't even know you had that in you.
Um...
Uh oh, I'm trapped.
But she also was like just getting poop everywhere.
Diarrhea.
And um...
And uh...
There was like poop in her...
Not poop.
There was blood.
There was blood in her poop.
It was just a mess.
I was like calling the emergency vet.
I was like...
What do I do?
And um...
Yeah, so...
I had a bit of a morning cleaning up all that.
Dealing with all of that.
So I was like...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna take it easy.
And you know what?
Minecraft is a bit of a comfort game for me.
Sounds like my weekend.
For you?
Out your butt?
But um...
I think she's better now.
What did I walk into?
Just my crazy afterlife.
But that's why she's hanging out with me.
Eek!
That's why she's hanging out with me.
In here.
We're just, you know...
Yeah.
That happened to my new kitten.
Turns out she was having issues with chicken.
Switched to no poultry diet.
I think that's it!
I think that's it because I feed Butaro chicken.
But I've been feeding her beef.
And then she ate the chicken and then she went crazy.
Isn't that right?
Isn't that right little girl?
You're so sweet.
She's so sweet though.
Beef.
I smell like beef.
Wow.
The open sea is under the moonlight.
What's over here?
Could it be another jungle?
Could it be a swamp?
The world...
Something like that.
Uh-oh.
Oh guys!
We're in trouble.
Oh we're in trouble.
No we're not.
Nah we're fine.
But what's her name?
Her name is...
Her name is... Drumroll, please.
Her name is Drumroll, please.
That's her name, actually.
So every time I can talk about her... That was not me, by the way.
Every time I talk about her, I can say, Drumroll, please!
She's the most well-experienced entrance cat ever.
To ever have an entrance.
Miss Drumroll, please.
Drumroll, please is such a cute name.
Thank you, I thought so too.
Actually, okay, I'll tell you for real.
Her name is... Drumroll, please.
Drumroll, please.
Perfect.
Beef is back on the menu.
I don't know why I'm so embarrassed telling you her name.
It's not even that embarrassing.
Oh wait, I should save this.
Okay, I'm gonna death by flower.
Come on, stand still.
What?
What is wrong with you?
There we go.
Perfect.
I should really...
I should really make a sword.
Okay.
Drumroll please!
Her name is Paz!
Get it?
Cause it's like...
Cat Paz, but it's Paz.
Isn't it cute?
Actually?
Right?
Actually cute.
Actually her name is Pacifica Ocean, but you know.
Sword.
I thought about...
What's the word?
Speedrunning stuff.
Attempting to speedrun.
For today's stream.
But I don't know.
I thought maybe you guys weren't ready for that kind of challenge.
That is Kojima level naming convention.
I don't know if she wants peace though.
So, it's even truly more fitting.
It's a little too intense for us.
Paz is also peace in Spanish.
Yeah!
That's why Paz is Paz in Metal Gear.
I'm sorry.
I gave my cat a Metal Gear name.
But you have to understand.
It's...
You have to understand who you're dealing with right now.
Is it Paz?
Like P-A-W-Z?
Or Paz?
P-A-Z.
It's just P-A-Z.
Whoa!
That's water?
It looks so awesome.
The reflection of it.
If you're wondering, I'm using complementary shaders.
Wait, so will we see other wolves as well?
Here?
Game looks nice.
It's the complementary...
Com...
Complementary...
Hum...
Something...
There's like a little tagline after it.
I don't remember.
Shaders.
No, more than shaders.
It was like...
Reloaded...
Matrix Revolution loaded.
Watching you play Minecraft, it just feels so right.
Words can't express the feeling of comfort I have right now.
Even though I've never played it.
On this channel.
That's good though.
Feel comfort.
Wait, maybe we can get some...
What's it called in here?
I need some...
We need some...
Stone.
But we also need...
Some coal.
Played it once.
You're so right.
Sorry.
Can't even remember my own lore.
I used streamer.
Used to watch.
Also used complementary stream...
Shaders.
I looked through the Minecraft setting for such a long time before I realized...
That didn't mean the shaders were...
Called complementary.
Wait, what do you mean?
If you google complementary shaders Minecraft, I'm pretty sure you'll get these, right?
Are you ever gonna play with mods?
Yes!
I would like to.
I just...
Didn't set it up this time.
We're like super bare bones today.
But...
In the future, there will be mods.
And stuff of the like.
Yes, yes.
I went to May Dreaming for the first time and second time recently.
It was amazing.
I can't wait to come back when I go to Japan again.
Oh my gosh, generic user!
Glad you liked it.
Maybe we can find a village and pillage their food.
For some coal, everybody.
Use your little wispy eyes.
I used my eyes!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I saw that!
Escape route.
No one here?
Good deal.
Yeah!
You guys were no help.
More.
We tried.
I thought about putting on a playlist of Minecraft music.
Instead.
But I don't know why some of the Minecraft music comes off very unsettling.
Some of it's just like kinda weird.
You know?
Some of it's like a little bit creepy.
Self help is the best help.
Hi Amori!
Let's skedaddle.
Skedaddle.
I said get out of here and skedaddle.
Let's skedaddle.
Let's skedaddle out of here.
Now we can cook our meats.
Backed.
Looking for a village, but I don't see one.
Skedaddle.
Hmm.
I want to find...
Cherry Blossoms.
That's where I will settle.
I used to do Minecraft plus Animal Crossing music.
That sounds like a good combo too.
Minecraft is a horror game hiding behind adventure.
Yeah.
I guess that's why, right?
The music is a little weird.
Hey Minty.
Do you know what tomorrow is?
Tomorrow?
Is it something special?
We are on a quest.
We are!
A Minty quest.
Oh!
I knew there would be a village.
Come on.
Pillage.
The village.
What are you...
What?
Huh?
I'm a...
I'm a dillo.
What?
Wait, can I take him?
How do I pick you up?
Wait, what do they like to eat?
An armadillo?
When did they add this?
Hold on, I want to hear what they sound like.
The other day?
Wait, what do you mean the other day?
These are brand new?
Oh my god, they are so cute.
What is your purpose?
What?
Why do you exist?
That is a chancre.
Don't fall in there.
Can they swim?
Look at him go.
His purpose is to be silly.
So true.
Oh my gosh.
First we got the wolves.
What else is new?
Oh my gosh.
It's like I'm playing Minecraft again for the first time.
Which is today.
Hello?
I'll take that.
Fine.
You have no job.
I was going to say a functioning village, but not quite.
Mhmm.
Hahaha.
Their purpose is to be slaughtered to make armors for dogs.
I know you're lying.
Don't say that.
Wow.
Stealing your food.
Wait, is that gonna...
How's it doing that?
How's your water just sitting there like that?
How's that happening?
Potion?
Do you have any beds?
Like where do you...
Where do you rest?
Oh!
Woah!
Heck yeah.
Can't see anything.
Where do you sleep?
Oh, up there probably.
How'd they get up there?
In here maybe?
No.
Is that like a temple?
Cool.
My bed now.
The shader...
This shader night darkness is crunchy with the video compression.
Oh no, really?
Take that.
Thank you.
May you never have a restful night again.
Solidus.
Crunchy.
Good morning world!
Good morning...
Minto!
Delicious.
Food that's not made by me is awesome.
You know?
Oha Minto!
Oha Minto.
I think I'm gonna steal that armadillo.
But also I'm curious if I kill him and see what happens.
I'm curious about death.
And killing.
She said the thing.
Oh there they go!
You can do it!
Just press space!
Oh!
You almost made it.
Are we good?
Are we back?
That wasn't YouTube.
I said OBS disconnected for a second.
Windows noises.
We're back?
That was so weird.
Surprised me even.
Classic OBS.
I won't tell you that that slip up to recover from a...
Wait.
That you use that slip up to recover from a death.
Don't worry.
What are you talking about?
I'm alive and I'm healthy and well.
I'll never die.
In this game.
I'm already dead.
I'll never die in game.
I've never died in game before.
Don't use that opportunity to create a montage of every...
What's going on?
Why do I keep disconnecting?
We're back?
Turtle six for the super.
Super chat.
I just saw.
Will you play with him?
Yeah, she loves Minecraft.
Yeah, I want to play with him.
Armadillo?
Where?
He's roll...
Oh my god.
I thought he was a...
If I run past them, they roll up?
Stop.
That's so cute.
Kick him.
Play soccer.
I'm playing soccer with this armadillo until OBS is better.
If you run past them, they just curl up into a little tiny ball.
How did he get all the way down there?
Did he roll?
Can they roll?
What?
He was just up here.
Right?
I'm not crazy.
There's no other guy.
You kicked him.
I didn't kick him.
Okay.
I'm gonna commit a crime.
Armadillo shields himself.
Armadillo peeks.
Hold on.
Leave the poor things alone.
You guys said it's for armor.
He didn't drop anything.
Dog armor.
Um...
My bad.
Oh, I should have done that when OBS disconnected.
I should have taken the chance.
When OBS disconnected to be a real criminal.
Did that make you feel powerful?
I'm not mad.
No.
So... I'm not quite sure how I feel right now.
I do feel a little bit evil.
And I like that feeling.
Add it to the list of crimes.
Crimes!
I have no list of crimes, you guys.
I'm a ghost maid.
I know I just finished watching Akiba maid war in those games.
In that series, they're all criminals, but not me.
Let's go punch some more wood.
Actually, no, I think we're good.
We might even be able to make stone.
Me?
I'm a simp?
Did you see Kojima's tweet about saying not bad?
Really?
No, I didn't see that, actually.
What was his first choice?
It was probably something too expensive.
Go away.
He didn't say.
But Sing was so perfect.
People are saying it was Imagine.
No, Sing was... I can't imagine...
I can't imagine it being anything like that.
Anything other than Sing.
I don't want to imagine another song.
Or I'll cry.
I can see it being Imagine.
What?
What is Imagine?
Is that Elton John?
There's a fire.
Imagine all the people.
No, see, it doesn't fit the vibe.
Wait, that's the Beatles, right?
Oh, John Lemon.
Imagine Dragons.
Len.
Nice.
No, it burned.
My food burned.
The Beagles.
No, I said the Beatles.
For what purpose?
To have a fried chicken.
Duh.
Think smarter, not harder.
Thanks for coming back, Mint.
You're welcome.
I could have just...
I should have taken the opportunity to book it.
I should have taken the opportunity to run.
Mint, you've changed.
This is what Minecraft does to you.
It turns you into a psychopath, I think.
No, I've always been the same.
I've always been the same.
Think smarter, not harder.
What?
What do you mean, what?
That's a real phrase.
Right every...
Oh, gosh.
We're okay.
That's a real phrase.
It means...
Think smarter, not harder.
Where you will do something because it's easier.
Work smart...
Wait, what do you mean?
What did I say?
Oh.
I'm thinking harder, you guys.
Maybe I do need to think harder.
What did she mean by this?
I don't need...
I don't think.
I don't know.
I don't even think.
Okay.
We're gonna go find some place to sleep tonight.
Some place I won't be disturbed.
What is this?
Rock formation.
Lava.
Shiori.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
I think we can sleep on top of this tiny block.
Here's my...
Ben.
Whatever this is...
Put it down...
Nice.
Woohoo!
Alrighty.
I'm back on my...
linking back to my full spit.
Okay.
All right guys.
I hope we didn't interrupt you while we were sleeping tonight with the just there like, ''What's she doing?!
''.
Wohoo!
I don't know what I'm doing.
What am I doing?
I'm playing... I'm playing... Minecraft.
Sorry, should I have said your full name?
Shiori Novella Novelite.
Wait, it's blocked off the rest of it.
Hold on.
I can't see your name, but thanks for the gift!
Let's go this way.
Next village we find, we're gonna bring them the gift of maids.
A maid cafe.
In their area.
This area kinda sucks.
Dolphins!
I'm so... what else?
Wait, okay.
What else have they added in the Minecraft then?
They added armadillos and they added...
What else have they added with the wolves?
Maybe we can go on a hunt for that.
Camels.
Music.
They got burgers now?
They added the deep dark?
I've been there before.
I just, you know, we can go.
It's just, you know...
I'm too cool for the deep dark.
They added some new discs.
Guns?
Burgers?
Wait, really?
And then...
First we have Shiori, then we have Narisa Ravencroft's...
All I see is Ass!
Her Ravencroftses!
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Oh my gosh.
Orgh!
I can't believe Advent is watching my stream.
Oh my goodness, what an honor.
Fire, fire, light the fire.
Dancing to the... something, something.
To a new world.
Alright, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
They added circles.
Don't lie to me.
This is Minecraft.
We need bibu and flamako.
I think you have to stick your giat out now.
Will that summon bibu?
Wow, how lucky.
I just stopped here, but I think it's actually a spot.
I think it's actually a nasty spot.
For nasty people.
I don't want to die here.
By drowning.
Wait, I'm going to become one of them?
Oh gosh.
That was close.
Coming out, idiot.
Don't you know how to leave?
Is there anything in here?
I can't see.
Oh wait.
Monster.
Maybe there's a chest.
I don't have a thing to get the sussy sand if there is any.
That's a sussy sand.
What's wrong with me?
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
There's another fire over there, you guys.
Everything's setting on fire.
Oh my god.
Koseki, bibu, sparkling platinum, jane of hololive, and thank you for the 10 gifted.
Oh here, I was going to do this.
Sticking out your gut for realiz... wait, nerizzler.
Your soapy butax.
Is there anything in here?
I don't want to destroy the sussy...
Oh no!
I can't open it.
I have to destroy the sussy sand.
How do we make the thing?
How do we make...
Copper and feathers.
What's it called though?
Oh my god.
Flower, moccoco, top, doggy, holy, defender, thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, advent.
We got them all.
I feel like the Pokemon master right now.
The infinity stones.
Welcome to membership, thank you so much.
What is this thing called?
Sand?
No, brush.
No.
What's it called?
Maybe I haven't unlocked it yet so I can't see it.
Maybe I haven't unlocked it so it won't show me this.
But let's go find some...
Some...
I think there probably will be some over here.
Copper.
Get bibu taxed.
Utano!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Oh, no.
That's iron.
Actually, we need this though.
Can I go plant this?
Perfect.
Bibu, welcome to membership, thank you!
Al and Chocobo, welcome to membership, thank you!
What's this?
Furnace.
Oh my gosh, we are actually playing the game now.
That's kind of crazy.
Okay.
Welcome to membership!
Take!
Does that mean you're kind of Captain Planet now or something?
With my five powers combined, I'm Captain Planet!
How did that song go?
Actually, I don't remember how the Captain Planet song used to go.
I didn't see this went live.
Hello!
I'm Captain Planet.
Captain Planet, he's a hero.
Gonna take pollution down to zero.
Gonna something plunder and...
Go to village, he will plunder.
Take everything till they surrender.
Did not rhyme.
Brush.
Oh!
Oh, feather!
We need a feather.
Oh my gosh.
There's gotta be chickens around here.
Oh, I don't know why I even thought that would be...
There's gotta be chickens here.
There's gotta be chickens.
We're playing hardcore mode, you guys.
If I die, we'll never know what's in those sands.
We'll never know.
That'll be my life.
Actually, I'm gonna go get my bed.
I'm gonna go get my bed.
So we can...
When it gets actually dark, we can sleep.
Pew!
Go!
Thank you for the silver Fangs!
I need bread.
I should also make my meat.
Gonna go make my meat.
Instead of copper.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Meat.
Alright, let's go look for a chicken.
I just need one damn chicken.
One damn chicken!
I need two damn chickens.
Did I get it?
Oh, here, here, here.
Run!
Oh, it's getting dark out.
Wait, I'm scared.
Oh, I can sleep.
Now you can feed Paz.
No!
I don't think she can have chicken!
I think she's allergic to chicken.
Oh, brush.
We are so back.
Nice.
Okay, it's my...
Okay, okay.
Sussy sand.
Destroy sussy sand.
Get stuff from...
the temple.
You just have to train her.
Woohoo!
Oh gosh.
Okay, I have a shovel.
I have a shovel.
Use your shovel!
Mint, what is wrong with you?
Why won't you...
Why would you use your shovel when you have...
Treasure map.
An emerald!
Oh, thank goodness this is not any further deeper.
Or we'd be so done-zo.
Did I make...
Oh yeah, here it is.
Undersea treasure.
Treasure!
Greetings from the Redmond side of Mojang.
Welcome back!
Thanks!
Huh?
From Mojang?
Real?
Nah.
I
can never tell when people are pulling my leg, you know?
What a peculiar map.
Mr Mojang himself!
Let's see.
What can I get rid of?
My dirt is really important.
But I think...
We'll put it like that.
People need to know someone's been here.
I will become the Herobrine of this world.
Take my food.
A mint-merled... yes.
Papita, thank you for the vibe!
Gifted!
Thank you so much!
Yeah, I'm going back for my stuff in here.
No worries.
But also, we have more... oh shoot.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
More sussy, sussy, sussy.
What is that?
Gold?
Gold.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Down.
Anymore?
Oh, here.
You know, you say put a door underwater to breathe.
Like you're some kind of genius or something.
You know, like you're some kind of like, you know...
Person that knows... you know, this is the thrill.
You know, the thrill of maybe not making it back.
I gotta feel like I might die in the ruins, okay?
Like that.
What a thrill.
You and Murphy were bad influences on me and now I'm officially importing a brand new Vuelix arcade cabinet from Japan.
I don't know what Murphy did to be a bad influence...
Warner!
Why did we get such a sad... a sad one?
Oh yeah, let's make the rest of our copper.
We don't really need it, but...
Somebody died.
Me!
Oh my gosh, we can put it in the maid cafe.
We can put it in the maid cafe.
Perfect.
Alrighty, let's get my pottery... I mean my...
Actually, I am gonna take this.
Here.
Hurry.
Please.
Axe.
The little axe that could.
Please!
Please axe!
I don't think I got it.
What can I lose?
That was close.
See the thrill.
The thrill of death.
Knocking at your door.
Remembers that a door is your...
No, no.
You don't want the door.
We're...
We're doing it...
Oh.
Oh, I don't need that.
What did I just throw?
Where's my...
Oh.
What am I grabbing?
Where's my...
How did that even get out there?
I threw my brush?
Where is the...
Why isn't it picking it up?
Eh?
Uh...
You guys?
I have an empty spot.
Oh, I somehow got rotten flesh.
Ghost chest.
And my...
My bamboo is missing too.
That's what I was trying to say earlier.
Where's the bamboo?
Eh?
Kargura...
Chonbot...
Chonbot Association.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the birthday gift.
You dropped the bamboo for space earlier in the diving.
Did I?
No, I thought I put it in the chest.
Did I not?
Did we lose the bamboo?
It's okay.
It was just one.
Let's go.
Treasure hunting.
Surely we'll find it.
We'll find something good.
Tingling.
There was a whole bamboo block.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Right?
But it disappeared.
So strange.
Maybe I am getting Herobrine.
Fire charge.
We're gonna take that back.
We're gonna transfer all of...
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Don't burn it.
We're gonna turn all of this into wood.
Okay.
I ate it.
Oh my gosh.
I thought that was a person.
Scared me.
Okay.
No.
So weird that it wouldn't pick up the chest earlier.
Herobrine.
Okay.
Let's go get us a treasure.
It wasn't in the mood.
We are...
Okay.
We're north east.
We need to go north.
No.
South.
We are north.
Okay.
We are fighting dreamers actually.
We are fighting dreamers.
See?
Snakes are the 10 gifted.
Why is everybody gifting so much today?
What is going on?
We're going off into the sunset.
Oh.
Maybe I should go to sleep.
No.
Let's go sleep over here.
Actually, no.
Part of the thrill is digging the treasure when you could die.
Oh, I'm speaking of.
Ducky, thanks for the...
Wow!
Thanks for the five gifts and thank you so much.
Fighting dreamers.
We are fighting dreamers.
I've never watched Naruto.
Fighting dreamers.
ID number one?
Wait, what does that mean?
ID number zero.
Oh, maybe because I'm holding...
Ramak, thanks for the gift.
Hmm...
Yeah, fine.
Here's a super chat instead.
I didn't ask for that either.
Are we going the wrong way?
West.
South.
Sockle.
Oh my god.
Chili Dutchies.
I think we gotta go through the land.
Hello.
Alright, time to fight for our lives.
Actually, I'm just gonna go to sleep.
Thanks, new ring.
Uh oh.
Are we gonna die?
Hey!
It's daytime!
Oh my god.
Ugh.
It's raw!
Did you guys get scared?
Don't get scared.
Everything was under control.
I had it all under control.
See, just listen to peaceful music.
Actually, I am gonna turn my game down just a wee bit.
How are you still alive?
Oh gosh.
Why is he...
glowing?
Oh my god.
It's still so loud.
Spiders can spawn with buffs?
Oh, there's another guy.
Wait, this guy has armor.
Wait, I kinda need you.
Gimme your stuff.
Dang.
Why do you have buffs?
What are his buffs?
Anyway, where were we going?
Oh no, we're past it.
We need to go...
north?
And then...
we need to go...
west.
This way?
Are we doing it?
No, this way.
This way?
No?
I'm confused.
My feet hurt.
Are we there yet?
I think I'm lost.
More west.
This way.
This way is west.
This is like the most west we could go.
Absolute west.
This way.
No, this way.
More west.
Are we almost there?
No.
I don't think so.
What are your favorite mods for Minecraft?
What mods do you enjoy the most?
Got your nose.
What are you talking about?
Wait, I'm in my bed.
Like this.
Oh!
Pies!
Can you guys hear her?
Pies, come here.
Come here.
I think she wants out.
She's a...
She's kind of a...
Are you yawning?
I thought there was something in the game, but it was her.
She's so, so cute.
Come here, pies.
Come here, come here.
She doesn't listen very well though.
This whole time?
Let's have my tongue out.
Come here.
Stop honking.
Come here, come here.
She doesn't listen very well.
I don't think she like...
Come here.
You sweet girl.
Yes, you are.
She just wants out.
Give me one second.
I think she opened the door.
But I think she's hungry.
Do you guys mind if I feed her real quick?
Give me two seconds to go feed my cat.
Okay, I'm so sorry.
We'll get some sweet jazz moments.
Give me one second.
I'm just gonna feed her real quick.
I'm so sorry.
I'm back.
I'll grab some snacks for me too.
I...
I have no idea how she opened the door.
Because I shut it.
It's so weird.
Anyway.
Clever girl.
She is clever.
Hmm.
Wait, I was so close.
What are we, crunching?
Sorry, I got like a little...
I got...
I have some snacks still from when I was in Japan.
It's not in the water, though.
Is it?
West.
This way.
This way?
How member please.
Um maybe maybe you can get lucky and so we'll gift it but fortunately I can't tell you other but it's okay you don't have to member don't worry about it.
Village.
Here.
Please don't break.
Oh nice.
Paperbacks thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
No I must.
I don't want anyone ever to feel like they have to um you know do something to like support me you know.
Iron sword.
Let's go baby.
Let's get some food.
You know what maybe I don't need the wool.
Hard to see I don't think we really need.
We don't really need.
Um Take that though.
Check that.
And oh wait.
Is this the same map?
00.
Yes.
So he can get rid of the maps too.
Very good.
Spades.
Speaking of JP Snacks, Jagariko, crunchy or stale?
Crunchy.
I think.
I don't know, I used to be a Jagabi fan because I thought it was a little softer and I kind of like that, but...
I mean, I thought they are softer than Jagariko, but now I'm kind of more for the Jagariko.
But for a long time, for a long long time, I was always for the Jagabi.
Which do you like?
Jagariko or Jagabi?
Umami flavor is high quality too.
Kathleen, thanks for the tiny gift.
Jagabi, Jagabi, Jagariko, Jagariko.
Haven't had either.
No JP Snacks for me.
Surely you can find some place that has some JP Snacks.
I've wanted to sign up for like a...
I don't know, some sort of like...
What's going on here?
Some sort of JP Snacks service because...
It's a whole lot of nothing, never mind.
I don't know, it's just kind of fun to like...
To anticipate something in the...
In the mail, you know what I mean?
Like a monthly like...
I'm gonna... Is that a graveyard?
I use Bokushu.
I've heard of Bokushu.
Never used it before though.
How about blue?
Bread!
Spruce.
But...
They're kind of expensive.
So I've never signed up for one.
Will you open up a PO box?
I don't really have plans to at the moment.
Oh my god, there's more fire everywhere we go!
I think Herobrine actually is following us.
I'll see what we can find.
Like, a truck to the Japanese stores in Manhattan.
That's so awesome.
Yeah, um...
I don't really plan on opening up a PO box...
because I would have to probably manage it myself.
I don't know what if I get something weird in there.
Maybe hopefully... hopefully I mean I would like a manager and then maybe... once I get a manager, whenever that time comes, I wouldn't be so... a throne?
I don't... I don't know.
Like I really don't... I would... I only really want a PO box for people to send me... oh my god we have a prisoner!
Only if people like wanted to send letters, right?
Like I don't want people to feel like they're having to buy me things.
And I don't really... I don't even know what I would put on a throne.
I kind of already have everything that I want.
I don't really need... it's kind of like when my mom is like what do you want for your birthday or Christmas?
I'm like I don't know.
I have everything that I need.
Toilet paper!
More arcade cabinets.
I went to an electronics store the other day and they had um... they had like tiny Wheel of Fortune cabinets.
Cabinets.
And Tiny... They had other ones.
What was it?
They had Tiny Wheel of Fortune.
Oh, Tiny... The Buck Wild.
Buck Hunting.
Go Wild.
They had that too.
Genji!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
You can get the TMNT arcade cabinet?
Brilliant.
Buck Wild.
Is that what it's called?
Look at that kid.
Wow, this village is nice!
It's really poppin'!
Like, we are good on food.
He's a scholar.
Skyripa!
Thank you for the...
5 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, this one's 2 stories!
Nice.
Wow, this is a really nice... It's huge!
I don't think I've ever seen a village this large before.
Rich man house.
Not up to code, but that's okay.
Rich no more.
Ouch!
Enjoy this mint colored super chat.
Oh my gosh, Gavin!
Hi, Gavin!
Thank you!
What the heck?
Where's my boat?
The man himself.
This guy made me move.
Ow!
Oh, get out.
Did I take my boat?
Did I leave it over here?
Where did I leave it at?
GMG, thank you for another 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Oh, here it is.
Alright, continuing onward.
Wait a second.
Didn't I say the next village we come across, we'll build them a maid cafe?
We'll show them the wonders of maid?
Yeah, make the maid cafe here.
Yeah, I said that, didn't I?
Okay.
We're gonna make it right here in the town center.
Oh, okay.
I'm already getting opposition...
to our maid cafe.
But that will not deter me.
I'm already receiving threats.
Divine intervention.
He would love to see a maid cafe outside his house.
I'm just saying.
That would be his number one priority.
Flagship cafe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now, the thing about this maid cafe is we can only make it with stuff that we already have.
So...
So,
it might be...
a place that only a mother could love.
Oh my god.
I thought that was a skele-man.
Budget cuts?
Pretty much.
Until we get more patrons...
we are flat broke.
We eat seaweed every day.
Um, let's set up...
a
furnace.
Okay.
Oop.
And I'm gonna start burning this, actually.
Like that.
Okay.
As a fellow ghost, have you been watching the Space Ghost Coast to Coast live on YouTube?
I'll be honest.
I actually watched a couple episodes.
I did.
I actually watched it just a little bit.
But I never watched Space Ghost before.
So, um...
But it's been showing up in my feed.
So, like, I'm like, yeah.
You know what?
Maybe I will watch some Space Ghost Coast to Coast.
Made Ghost Coast to Coast.
Love Space Ghost.
I always liked, um...
Uh...
I never had watched it, but I always liked the little...
the little...
bug guy.
What's his name?
But it's funny because I had watched a...
Zorak.
Yeah.
Actually, wait.
There's the other guy.
I don't know how to describe what he said.
How he looks.
The hysterical laughter of Mint makes my day better.
What do you mean by that?
The other guy.
Motar?
Hold on.
I'm gonna look him up.
Mo...
The
guy that has the sharp teeth.
He's so cute.
The Zorak.
What's the guy?
Not the guy in the suit.
Brak?
Motar is cool, though.
Yes!
He's so cute!
Why do you already have diamonds?
Let's just say...
a certain developer...
gifted me.
Let's just say...
the odds are in my favor.
my dad works at Mojang.
Okay.
We're gonna have to mix...
and match, baby.
This is the first store.
It's very small.
But that's because we only have, like...
one person working here.
But...
Um...
Oh, we have lots of spruuuce!
We have so much spruce.
But I have an idea for this.
Watch, watch.
Watch how cute this is gonna be.
Where's my shovel?
Ah,
it broke.
Um...
What you call me?
Look.
I may be having hard times, but...
just flat out saying I broke is really...
little...
Like, I get out my situation okay.
They told me on Twitter to stop buying candles, but i just...
They told me on Twitter to stop buying candles,
See it's already shaping up really well, right?
And then it's going to be a double door here.
Made of a mysterious wood.
Door.
Made of... No, I don't want spruce.
I want them to be able to see in and see what they're missing out on.
Made of a jungle.
Yes.
They're eating Mike Tyson's eyes!
No!
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Are you guys seeing the vision?
You guys are seeing the vision.
I know it.
Oops.
Actually, this is where we keep...
This is where we keep our money.
What is that emoji?
What was that person's face?
Thank you.
Real Yago.
Very real.
Thank you.
Bat chest?
What is that?
It's a Twitch emote?
Oh.
Now we have lots of glass.
Who... What's the emote?
Oh.
Wait.
Bat.
Bat chest.
Who is that?
A
legend.
There's too many legends.
You know?
You can't call everybody a legend.
Because then nobody is a legend.
You guys.
There's only one legend.
No.
If you could only have one legend.
Who are you picking?
Turtle chirps?
Since when do turtles chirp?
Turtles make noise.
Mint phantom.
I'm a legend.
Minecraft.
Steve.
You're the big legend.
I can only...
The world doesn't need any more legends.
Is Mint a skinny legend?
Ha ha ha.
Possibly.
Um.
We're not open yet, sir.
You guys.
This town was craving a maid cafe.
They're foaming at the mouth for this place.
They're ready to be served.
They're
ready to be served.
Maybe we should have a turtle.
Oops.
Uh oh.
We might have to do an open air concept.
Oh, I have one here too.
I'm ready to serve.
Master.
Oh.
A glass roof?
Good idea.
Okay.
You guys see the vision?
What are you serving?
A knuckle sandwich.
Whoopah!
I
thought I had more stuff.
Serve turtles.
What do you think we're...
Inhumane?
Imagine a bank run by maids.
Call it a paid cafe.
More like...
More like you're...
They take your money.
Cafe.
Sorry.
I don't know where I was going with that one.
Very intuitive.
Cool.
Thank you.
Why do you guys watch me?
Oh, my shaders.
Oh no!
Please, sir.
Please, you gotta help me.
Sir.
I heard you leave.
Oh, my gosh.
This place needs me.
I wonder that myself.
I wonder that every single day of my afterlife.
I wonder every single day.
Fire, fire, light the fire.
Precisely for this.
Does it make you...
Does it build your confidence a little bit?
Or are you just like, gosh.
How dumb is that, girl?
Can we make the Rainforest Cafe?
I mean...
It's a maid cafe.
It can be any theme that we like it to be.
What are you doing out here?
This is the jungle.
This is...
What are you talking...
This is the Russian jungle.
Get out of here.
You're gonna die.
Did I get these places?
I can't remember what I've robbed and what I haven't.
Oh, my God.
This is useless out here.
Living off the land, not paying his taxes.
Not even with a job.
Make it a rainforest theme.
Okay.
Get rid of him.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh, a cat.
What?
Where did he go?
I feel called out?
No, you're perfectly fine.
Cause you're...
Oh, oh.
If a tree falls in a forest and no one's around, Does it make a sound?
Does it make a sound?
Like how he's getting mad at me?
He can't get mad at me.
You have no job!
You guys, he...
We have to...
Actually, maybe we could've hired him at the maid cafe.
Maybe we should've...
Maybe we could've hired him at the maid cafe.
You killed a potential customer or employee.
Make babies!
Where do you...
Good!
They already have a baby.
No?
What do you mean you disagree?
With bread?
Take it.
Alright.
Make babies!
Here we go.
Oh yes!
Oh my god!
Make babies!
I need more customers!
Why won't you populate?
This guy is so stupid.
No, make baby.
Make baby.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bread.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
It's happening.
It's happening!
Where is...
Ah!
Wait, there's more trapped people.
How many people are trapped in these things?
Be free.
There you go.
Wait, this village is actually popping off.
I'm into the voyeur.
Don't do it.
I only have 25.
I can't repair you every time.
Fine.
There you go.
Let's see.
This guy too.
And the cat.
Okay.
This is your first time playing Minecraft?
Well, technically, it's like my first time playing the normal Minecraft.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh my gosh.
What?
This baby took my bed.
How dare.
You're working for me.
Hold on.
Okay.
No, no, no.
Come back.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
That's gonna catch on fire.
Maybe not.
Oh.
I don't have a way to break this.
How did they get out?
I don't think I have a way to break.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
Get in there.
Yes.
No, no, no, no.
Kid, kid, kid, kid, kid.
Oh, he'll be back.
He'll be back, Lemon.
You'll be back.
Okay.
We don't have time to worry about this kid right now, though.
We have a main cafe to build.
He's wary of my ways?
No.
He's familiar with this island.
I want him to work for me.
He's an orphan.
His parents are dead, probably.
No joke, you just made my mantis egg hatch.
What did I... Am I a mom?
What did I... Huh?
How did I... How did that happen?
Huh?
Is that a euphemism?
I don't...
I don't know.
Huh?
Am I a mom?
Oh, he's a cartographer now.
He's working right here.
Okay.
We might have to have a glass roof.
And not in like the... you know...
Break the glass ceiling kind of way.
But I'm gonna put pumpkins on each of them.
On each corner.
For a little bit of flair.
In our... In our...
In our...
Rainforest-made cafe.
Mother!
He posted literal praying mantis eggs.
He is being as literal as it is possible to be.
But what did I do to cause this?
Was it my charm?
Did they say like... Oh my god.
Who is this sweet, angelic voice we hear?
We must be born so we can identify the cause...
Of this.
Yes.
You have that fertile aura...
Let's not say it like that.
I am not Chihuahua.
I am Fuwawa.
I am not Fuwawa.
I am Mokuko.
Together we are...
Fuwamokowawa.
Don't push me.
This is my house.
What happened to you?
Again.
Why is nobody visiting yet?
Oh.
Well, we don't have any tables or anything.
It's okay.
We'll have it soon.
No worries.
There are no maids.
Not yet.
Not with that attitude.
Am I nothing to you?
Am I not a maid?
I'm right here.
And they will come.
Okay.
Thank you for your wise wisdoms.
You're the only maid I want, man.
Stop it.
I'm just gonna take these back if you're not gonna use them, you know?
I'm just gonna take those back if you're not gonna use them.
What will you serve in the cafe?
Good question.
Might I interest you in salmon?
Freshest in the sea?
Or perhaps...
Perhaps...
Priest.
Just a little priest.
Oh.
I almost fell through.
Don't say it.
Please not him.
He's too gummy.
He's a gummy kid.
Start up an armory so you can have plenty of armaments.
She's gonna serve humans.
Yeah, I am.
I'm serving them as my masters.
Duh.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Now I can watch how the goings-on in the maid cafe are from above.
Kiwawa and Hennyeo were both serving something recently.
I won't say it.
You can't make me.
You can't make me say it.
You can't.
I won't.
You won't catch me saying it.
I'm trying it.
You won't catch me!
But it's okay if my Oshis say it.
Just not me.
My Oshis can say whatever they want.
Oh wait, how do we...
Oh we need to get some clay, right?
For our sherd.
Oh...
Surely, there is some down here.
Oshis are without flaw or blame.
Exactly, exactly.
That's why it's okay if they say it.
Do we get a V here?
As a woman, I finally saved the last five dollars for my rent.
Now I can not get kicked out...
Stop!
Don't send it to me then!
My cunt is sad now.
Who?
Why are you talking in third person like a weirdo?
Wait, is it this one?
What?
You know Mike?
Some things...
Some things are just really hard to remember.
But sometimes as a streamer, there are things that you must remember.
And I fell...
I broke that rule.
My
man Mike is important to me.
I'd never forget about him.
That guy ruined my life.
My afterlife even.
Oh, I think I'm...
Oh god!
Oh no!
I died because of my cunt!
It's all your fault!
Mike!
Why would you do this to me?
You!
Oh my...
The vape cafe!
Wait, they just disappeared.
What happened?
Oh, here they are.
You!
Where were you?
It's literally your job.
I cannot believe I did it just in time.
Okay, RiseKnight.
Okay.
Okay, right.
Okay, RiseKnight.
Okay.
I can't believe you!
Where were you?
Oh...
Ah...
I heard them coming!
I was just about to get in the shower and I heard the screams.
I just want to say rip Bozo.
Wow!
Wow, look how beautiful it was down here.
Woah!
Diamond?
Mods ban that man.
Where are you?
Who was it?
It was Customer Johnson, wasn't it you?
That sent me about Mike?
Right?
I can't believe Mint died of ligma.
Shut the hell out Lily, please.
Shut up.
Oh!
We're in... oh!
I don't know!
What's going on?
Ow!
What's that over there?
I think I see the light.
No, this is the village!
I died!
Hardcore mode is suffering.
What's that down there?
I wonder if we can find something interesting.
Oh, it just looks so square.
I thought it was like...
The world... oh, we're back.
Oh, we're back.
We're gone and we're back.
You are a specimen.
What does that mean?
What does that even mean?
That is so rude!
I'm more than a specimen!
Literal, actual, god...
Stop laughing at me!
I'm going to...
What happened?
Why suddenly creative?
Nothing.
I got bored of playing the game for real.
Well, everybody...
I wonder if it will let me do this.
Stop pausing!
It had to be done.
Did it?
Did it, customer support?
Customer...
Sorry.
You know, usually when you say customer support...
I mean...
Sorry.
You know, in the end, I can't do it anymore.
Now I'm trying to think of a way to make it easier for you.
Oh, no!
No, you can't.
I'm the one who's the one who's scared...
Yeah, yeah, you can just stop laughing at me.
I know what you're going to say.
First or second, uh, thank you.
Okay.
Um, wait, back to game.
I'm going now!
But every time I click out of Minecraft, it puts up the...
It does that, so it doesn't, um...
I can't really zoom out.
Your comedic typing is so perfect that an outsider would think it's a crimson.
What do you mean?
What is that?
Wait, what is that up there?
Do you see that?
Wait, what is that in the sky?
What is that?
Oh my god, it's the village!
It's the village.
I keep seeing these things...
I'm actually crying, you guys.
This isn't funny anymore and I'm tiny and I can't get big.
I'm small and the world is...
See, this is what I'm seeing.
Help me, please!
This is like, uh...
Like, mosquito simulator.
What if I just keep going forever?
Hold on.
This way.
I'm dying now.
I'm dying.
Well, I'm already dead.
I'm dead.
I'm going back to heaven.
Because of my cunt.
Thank you.
For joining me on this afterlife journey.
Don't fall for...
Don't fall for the name.
See you in another four years, Mitt.
Where are we?
Still in the void.
Okay.
It's nice and bright up here.
I'm basically toasting.
I'm toasting.
I'm frying.
I'm sizzling.
Don't go into the light.
I am the light.
I will be a guiding light in your sad lives so that you never say bad things again.
I wonder where we are.
Like actually.
I wonder if it will load.
Aren't you supposed to spectate the world?
I guess it's gone.
Praise the sun.
Praise the sun!
Doesn't work properly on Java edition yet.
Anyway.
That was silly, wasn't it?
That was pretty goofy, wasn't it?
Give pies lots of pets.
Osumito.
No, no, no, no, no.
Let's make another world.
It doesn't have to be hardcore.
I'm so sad.
Made world Outer Heaven Busted Z.
We'll never be able to go back to you.
That's so sad.
Next.
Oh!
It loads so fast!
I feel like I remember in the past, worlds used to take like a long time to load.
We are back!
This time, better than ever.
Savannah...
Oh, I forgot to do the...
I forgot to put hardcore.
You guys, I forgot to put hardcore.
I would like to do a server.
Or join a server.
I have talked with Henya and Mousey about maybe...
If they want to give me a tour of maybe the Vishojo server.
But it kind of scares me because...
Oh gosh, I'm going to die.
No, I'm not going to die.
It kind of scares me because they have so many mods.
So I'm a little intimidated by it.
But we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
Their mod pack is awesome.
I've only watched like...
Like Henya play.
And I was like, this doesn't even feel like Minecraft.
But...
It would be fun.
To try at least.
And...
I haven't entirely given up on the...
Server...
My own server...
For people to play.
I just...
I still just don't know...
What to do entirely yet.
Is all.
Make it a hardcore server.
That would be so intense, wouldn't it?
I wonder if there's any armadillos.
But yeah.
So...
Hopefully next time I play Minecraft...
I just kind of...
Like I said, I wanted to play something that was...
There's the armadillo!
I want to play something that was a little bit more of my...
Comfort.
Since I had a...
Crazy day today.
Did you just start a forest fire?
Now I didn't.
No new wolves are so cute.
They're so sweet.
Little brown dogs.
Little dogs.
But yeah.
Sorry.
I'm just kind of like...
Running and...
I'm afraid of this ghost.
You shouldn't be...
You shouldn't be real.
Oh my gosh.
And there's a jungle right over here.
Maybe we'll get a panda.
Casually sets the forest on fire.
No, these look the same.
Maybe they're a little...
They're a little...
I can't tell.
Maybe it's the lighting.
Are they the same as those dogs?
I can't tell.
Ouch.
This is how I make food sometimes.
In Minecraft, obviously.
Don't touch me.
Come back.
There we go.
See?
Fire pig.
But yeah.
Because I'm... hopefully I will be on a server next time, whether it be my own or probably most likely somebody else's.
But yeah, thank you guys for joining me tonight.
I know it's a bit of a shorter stream, but I just wanted to kind of hang out a little bit since I did not stream yesterday for the profile picture things.
I realized too, I also forgot to put this up, but I will in fact, rather than having it be like, you know, pay for me to draw it, I'm going to put up like a Google form for anybody who's interested.
And it's going to be kind of like more lottery based.
So that way, you know, you don't have to be like, oh, I can't donate $100.
So anybody can have the chance to get a profile picture drawn.
And gotcha pog.
Yeah, but it's free gotcha.
It's free gotcha.
Because, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So that's what I plan to do.
I think I'll have the stream on Sunday since I didn't do it.
Sunday.
This time, do another Sunday.
But what if we want to keep throwing money at you?
Well, that's very generous of you, but I don't want people to feel like they are always having to throw money at me.
I just thought, like, I just thought, like, I don't know, I don't want to exclude anybody.
So, hmm.
Pogs.
No, we love it.
Stop!
So yeah, I'll do that.
And I wonder how fast we can get blown up by a creeper.
Hold on, I'm gonna, I'm gonna cut down a tree.
We're gonna die, we're gonna die here.
And we're gonna dig down.
I will aggressively throw money at Mint.
No jokes on you fans.
Just free for the freak out to.
Nooo!
Thank you for the 10k!
Thank you!
But seriously, seriously...
There will probably be quite a bunch of people that will want to participate.
Oh wait, we can go down here.
So I'll probably just do like a handful for the stream.
And then...
And then I can do it again another time.
When I ultimately don't get to everybody.
Hello, where are the...
Where are the bad guys?
I'm trapped.
What was this about free super time?
No, stop throwing what?
Thank you!
Did someone say free super?
No!
I mean, I certainly did not.
Wait, oh wait.
If I can do this...
Hold on.
I might be...
Thinking with portals right now.
I might be thinking with portals right now.
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Free, free, free.
Wait, hold on.
No way!
I just read it!
I didn't... No, please.
Okay.
We're gaming.
Yeah, we're gaming.
Okay, here we go.
Time to dig down, baby!
Valentine, thank you for the 50.
Thank you!
Oh, we got some coal.
I hear a spider.
Keep going.
Keep going!
We hit a mine.
Free.
Why is there a...
Or a deep slate.
Why is there a emote that just says free?
Thank you guys for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know why you guys are always spoiling me.
I just wanted...
If I don't...
I heard...
I can't see anything.
There's the hole!
Can you guys see anything?
Do you have food?
No, we're here to die, baby.
But I hear lava.
You could make torches.
You're right!
You're so right.
There we go.
Now I can see.
Is it right here?
It's so dark.
You guys, we're gonna die.
We almost did...
Why is there an emote that just says free?
Free stuff.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the aqua super.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Also, wait.
I think there was another one that I missed earlier.
Hold on.
Wait, there was another aqua super I missed earlier.
Wasn't there?
Oh gosh.
I'm so sorry.
I was so distracted by the customer.
And the mic and everything.
Oh, there it is.
Oh no, YouTube is...
Shiori!
A big aqua super shared between us.
The Advent Fan Club.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Advent is lucky to have good fans.
Okay, here we go.
She likes Mike more than us.
No!
Spooked me for a second.
I thought it was lava.
I thought we were about to die.
When will we die?
Thank you for the 50.
Turns out the...
20th is free.
Oh!
Uh oh.
Wait, but I'm supposed to die.
Uh...
Hold on.
Let's dig through here.
Into the lava beyond...
S...
810!
Thank you for the aqua super!
It's not free.
It's definitely not free.
What?
I just got the weirdest...
notification.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
I wonder.
Hold on.
You...
Oh!
Interesting.
I just got a notification.
Okay, so this stream will probably not be monetized.
Because it says we just got...
We just detected audio in your stream...
belonging to someone else.
And your stream might be blocked.
No!
Don't block my stream!
Please.
YouTube!
I'll turn down the jazz.
Is that what's gonna do it?
Not the jazz!
You guys, we're gonna lose her.
We're gonna...
There it is.
There it goes.
Oh, wait.
We can make another.
Okay.
Make another.
It's from when you sang Imagine.
Imagine all the people.
Valentine, thank you for the 50!
Okay, I think maybe we need to dig up a little bit.
If we're still hitting...
Bedrock.
Bring the workbench with you?
You're probably right.
How is it so hard to die in this game, you know?
Customer Johnson.
I will not make that.
I will not be made a fool twice.
I will not be made...
Fool me once.
Shame, shame, shame.
Shame on me.
Valentine, thank you for the 50!
Oh, I hear the lava.
This way.
Forward.
Oh, that was weird.
Come on.
Death said no.
It was so easy for me to die before.
I hear it.
Wait.
Did that drip?
No.
This is making me nostalgic.
For what?
But...
I wanted to kind of discover like a cool place, but...
Dying in the lava I guess is okay too, you know?
If I die...
I can't...
Oh, lava popping here.
Oh, there's a bat!
There's a bat!
Oh, the bat just burned.
I don't know what happened to the bat.
The bat just burned in the lava.
Lava.
Lava popping.
Wait, what?
Nutty putty caves?
No!
Don't say that!
Goodbye bat.
She died once, she can't die twice.
The lava is literally around us.
Please.
Please!
Where are you?
I tried slash kill.
I don't have cheats on.
Can you slash kill?
Keep digging.
We'll get there.
We'll get to an opening.
Please.
Lava popping.
Bats are screeching.
Why is it so hard to die in this game?
Is it a bot feed?
It sounds right next to me.
It sounds like the next block I break will be it.
Oh my god.
Where's the lava?
I don't want to die to a skelly.
I don't want to die to your dumb ass.
Oh, diamond.
At least we get diamond before we die!
Did it glitch?
What's the wrong?
What's the wrong axe?
I didn't even think about it.
Because I just always have like a diamond or iron.
At least an iron axe.
I just always...
You know what?
Okay, skelly man.
You can get me.
Come on.
Put me out of my misery.
Score one.
Mint one.
Skelly zero.
Whoa!
I think I broke Minecraft.
Alright.
Since it doesn't like my late night jazz.
Let's put on some Minecraft music.
It's like, hey, hey.
We detected some music.
You're going to get in trouble.
Minecraft?
Play.
Play your music.
Minecraft.
There it is.
That was silly.
In the end.
We kind of build a maid cafe.
And we kind of...
No, not at all.
We did find the cherry blossoms.
But we did kind of build a maid cafe.
It
was a pretty useless Minecraft.
Yummy.
Welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you.
We've detected audio in your stream.
You guys.
If this stream gets blocked because of my jazz.
I'm so sorry.
If it gets blocked because of my jazz.
I am so sorry.
Sorry.
I thought it'd be fine.
But it's okay.
If it just gets demonetized.
Then it's whatever.
I hope you can join the bishoujo server.
Yeah.
I will hopefully have someone.
To guide me around.
And...
I don't know.
Any other servers I can join.
We'll see.
YouTube does not like jazz.
Not like jazz.
It's so sad.
Haven't they...
Haven't they watched the bee movie?
The cat is finally suing you.
For all the...
My eyes go kind of crazy when I do that.
It's like the...
What's it called?
I've seen that girl that does like the...
No Chick-fil-A sauce?
That's how I feel when I do that.
If you don't know what that is.
Don't worry about it.
You do the noise so well.
Thank you.
Huh?
Well guys.
I'm gonna go eat dinner actually.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you for letting...
Thank you for...
You know what?
Always thank you for letting me just kind of indulge myself with the dumb things that I like.
Um...
You guys let me do stupid Minecraft.
Even when it's just me going on a boat.
Listening to jazz.
Going through the night.
And doing nothing.
I really...
You guys are here for no reason.
But...
I really appreciate it.
Regardless.
Um...
We love dumb things.
I know sometimes...
Like people will be like...
In Minecraft they just...
Like...
They don't do anything in it.
And that was truly this stream.
So...
We'll play Minecraft and just run around and jump.
And just look at stuff.
But they never do anything.
And that was truly this stream.
But...
I appreciate you guys watching regardless.
Even though I wasn't building anything.
Or...
But this was my first time getting into Minecraft.
Um...
In a long time.
So...
It was kind of just nice to...
And I got to see the armadillos and the new wolves.
So that was good.
That was good.
Here for the bits and banter.
Literally here for your doing nothing antics.
I appreciate it.
I really appreciate it.
I don't deserve it.
But I'm very very very...
Very appreciative.
Thank you guys.
Tomorrow!
We are not doing nothing.
Tomorrow we are being awesome and cool as hell.
Tomorrow we are...
We are...
We are on the cruise.
Tomorrow...
Oh...
Tomorrow we are being cool.
Tomorrow...
Tomorrow we are being awesome.
Um...
Oh my goodness.
I'm looking at the stream labs now.
Surely those are free.
No!
Built a maid cafe and died.
This is secretly a mint lore stream.
Tomorrow we are being radical.
And awesome and cool.
And um...
Kao wabunga?
Cool.
And um...
Um...
Yeah.
Otominto everybody!
Otominto!
I feel like I lost my mind a little bit today's stream, so...
I'm gonna go check on...
Unpies.
I'm gonna go make sure she's all good.
I've just been kinda trying to make sure she's...
I've been...
Like...
Since she was in here, I thought I could watch her the whole time, but she wanted to leave, so...
Um...
She definitely lasted longer in here than Butaro, because he never likes to listen to my voice.
He hates me.
But I'm gonna go check on the little girl, make sure she's okay.
My little princess.
Otominto!
Thank you guys!
Busted!
Otominto!
See you guys.
I'm like...
No, that guy deserves no Otsu.
That guy deserves no Otsu.
Bye!
Get it?
This music's making me sad.
Okay.
Bye-bye!
Wait, I think my mic might be on, because I had to change mic stuff.
So, if you hear me...
Can I do the outro?
No, you didn't.
Peace!